- In other videos, we had started talking
about the types of bonds that might form
between atoms of a given element.
For example, if you have
two metals forming a bond,
well, you are going to
have a metallic bond.
If you have two nonmetals,
engaged in some type of bonding activity,
this is likely to be a covalent bond.
And the general rule of thumb is
if you have one metal,
and one nonmetal,
that this is likely to be an ionic bond.
These are the general rules of thumb.
What I wanna do in this
video is to better appreciate
that bonding is really more of a spectrum.
There are bonds,
and we've talked about things
like polar covalent bonds,
that start to look a
little bit more and more
ionic in nature.
And so that's what we're
gonna talk about in this video
and think about it in the
context of electronegativity.
Just as a reminder, we talk
about electronegativity
in many videos,
but this is the property
of an atom that's in a bond
to hog electrons,
to want the electron
density to be closer to it
for the electron pairs to spend more time
around that particular atom.
So, something with a
high electronegativity
is going to be greedier with the electrons
than something with a
low electronegativity.
We can think about the spectrum between
at this end you have ionic,
and at this end you have covalent.
And one way to think about it
is at the extreme left end,
you don't have much difference
in electronegativities.
Both atoms that are
participating in the bond
are roughly equal in how
badly they want the electrons.
While in an ionic bond,
you have a very big difference
in electronegativities,
so much so that one of the
atoms swipes an electron
from the other.
So, one way to think about it is,
let me draw a little bit of an arrow here,
so this is increased electronegativity
difference as you go from left to right.
And some place in the middle,
or as you go from left to right,
you're becoming more
and more polar covalent.
So for example, if you have a bond
between oxygen and hydrogen,
these are both nonmetals.
So this will be a covalent bond
by just our general rule of thumb.
And actually the division
between metals and nonmetals,
I'm gonna make it right over here,
it's this blue line is one
division you could view,
although things that straddle it
are a little bit more interesting.
But oxygen and hydrogen
are both nonmetals,
but you have a pretty big
difference in electronegativities.
This right over here is electronegativity
measured on a Pauling scale,
named after the famous biologist
and chemist, Linus Pauling,
and you can see on that
scale oxygen is a 3.44,
one of the most electronegative atoms.
Electronegativity trends, we
talk about in other videos,
goes from bottom left to top right.
The things at the top right
that are not the noble gases,
these are the ones that really
are greedy with electrons.
And oxygen is one of the greediest.
While hydrogen, it's
not not electronegative,
but it's lower, at 2.20.
So in this scenario,
those electrons are
going to spend more time
around the oxygen.
If they spent an equal amount of time,
that oxygen might be neutral,
but since they're spending
a little bit more time here,
we'll say that has a
partial negative charge,
the Greek lowercase letter delta,
and on the hydrogen side
because the shared electrons
are spending more time
around the oxygen than
around the hydrogen,
you would have a partially
positive charge right over there.
And so this would be
a polar covalent bond.
Maybe on the spectrum it
sits right over there,
depending on how you wanna,
how you view this scale.
Now the other question you say is
okay, this is a spectrum
between covalent and ionic,
what about metallic?
Well, metallic bonds are in
general going to be formed
if you have two things
that are not so different
in electronegativity,
and they both have reasonably
low electronegativities.
So that's why things on the
bottom left right over here,
if you have two of these forming bonds
with each other somehow,
that you're likely to have metallic bonds.
And that makes sense
because in metallic bonds
you have all the electrons
kind of mixing in
in a shared pool,
which gives some of the
properties like conductivity.
And so if you have a lot of things
that are fairly similar
in electronegativity,
and they're all low in electronegativity,
they might be more willing to
share those valence electrons
in a communal pool.